I think it was Elon that said that uh
gbt is too woke
uh is gpt2 woke as can you still imagine
the case that it is and not this is
going to ours
um question about bias honestly I barely
know what woke means anymore I did for a
while and I feel like the word is
morphed so I will say I think it was too
biased and
will always be there will be no one
version of GPT that the world ever
agrees is unbiased
what
I think is we've made a lot like again
even some of our harshest critics have
gone off and been tweeting about 3.5 to
four comparisons and being like wow
these people really got a lot better not
that they don't have more work to do and
we certainly do but I I appreciate
critics who display intellectual honesty
like that yeah and there there's been
more of that than I would have thought
um we will try to get the default
version to be as
neutral as possible but as neutral as
possible is not that neutral if you have
to do it again for more than one person
and so this is where more steerability
more control in the hands of the user
the system message in particular
is I think the real path forward
and as you pointed out these nuanced
answers to look at something from
several angles yeah it's really really
fascinating it's really fascinating is
there something to be said about the
employees of a company affecting the
bias of the system 100
uh we try to avoid the
SF
group think bubble
um it's harder to avoid the AI group
think bubble that follows you everywhere
there's all kinds of bubbles we live in
100 yeah I'm going on like uh around the
world user tour soon for a month to just
go like talk to our users in different
cities
and I can like feel how much I'm craving
doing that because I haven't done
anything like that since in years
um I used to do that more for YC and to
go talk to people in super different
contexts
and it doesn't work over the Internet
like to go show up in person and like
sit down and like
go to the bars they go to and kind of
like walk through the city like they do
you learn so much
and get out of the bubble so much
um
I think we are much better than any
other company I know of in San Francisco
for not falling into the kind of like SF
craziness but I'm sure we're still
pretty deeply in it but is it possible
to separate the bias of the model versus
the bias of the employees
the bias I'm most nervous about is the
bias of the human feedback Raiders uh so
what's the selection of the human is
there something you could speak to at a
high level about the selection of the
human Raiders this is the part that we
understand the least well we're great at
the pre-training Machinery
um we're now trying to figure out how
we're going to select those people how
like how we'll like verify that we get a
representative sample how we'll do
different ones for different places but
we don't we don't know that
functionality built out yet
such a fascinating
um
science you clearly don't want like all
American Elite University students
giving you your labels well see it's not
about I just can never resist that dig
yes nice
but it's so that that's a good
there's a million heuristics you can use
that's a to me that's a shallow
heuristic because uh Universe like any
one kind of category of human that you
would think would have certain beliefs
might actually be really open-minded in
an interesting way so you have to like
optimize for how good you are actually
answering doing these kinds of rating
tasks
how good you are empathizing with an
experience of other humans that's a big
one like and being able to actually like
what does the world view look like for
all kinds of groups of people that would
answer this differently I mean I have to
do that uh constantly instead of like
you've asked this a few times but it's
something I often do you know I ask
people
in an interview or whatever to Steel Man
uh the beliefs of someone they really
disagree with and the inability of a lot
of people to even pretend like they're
willing to do that is remarkable
yeah what I find unfortunately ever
since covid even more so that there's
almost an emotional barrier it's not
even an intellectual barrier before they
even get to the intellectual there's an
emotional barrier that says no anyone
who might possibly believe
X
they're they're an idiot they're evil
they're malevolent anything you want to
assign it's like they're not even like
loading in the data into their head look
I think we'll find out that we can make
GPT systems way less biased than any
human yeah
so hopefully without the
because there won't be that emotional
load there yeah the emotional load
but there might be pressure there might
be political pressure oh there might be
pressure to make a bias system what I
meant is the technology I think will be
capable of being
much less biased